i don't want to pay for it i just want
to watch it
that's absolutely amazing it is
absolutely amazing now here's what's
amazing we just played that in here and
i watched you go oh god what what are
you thinking when you see that i hate
listening back to myself i hate it
a recording artist yeah i know but i
just don't like listening back to myself
i don't know why when you listen to that
do you think it's not good no i just
a cringe i don't know why like whenever
i listen back to anything
that i do oh that sounds like
whenever i listen back to something that
um
i do it just makes me feel weird even
now or looking back on old stuff no even
now
really yeah so but when you're in a
studio and you take and they do a take
of whatever you're going to record don't
you have to listen to it back
yeah but it's like i don't know how many
songs have you recorded since that day
oh absolutely lord
no you can't even count it goes in loads
not numbers in weight they do so seven
loads of songs
songs by weight
load is not a weight a load is a number
oh that's how they talk in northeast
okay in the northeast of england where
are you from you're from are you you're
not from leeds
you don't like the pillow no it's not
cool what city are you from what's wrong
it's just through the pillow away yeah
what do you know that was a pillow given
to me by my grandmother who said in as
long as that pillow stays on your couch
you'll have good luck
oh and what did you just do with my
grandmother's pillow i'm sorry
what did you do with my grandmother's
pillow where did you put it on the floor
and now there's no more good luck for me
and um
i forgot what i was going to say it
doesn't matter no it really are you
uncomfortable with the i noticed you're
putting the head no it's fine it's just
my head so big
your hair is bigger your head's bigger
what's happening oh wait here's here's
uh do you remember her
yeah this is a this is a makeup artist
wendy just came in my dad's makeup
artist just came in with a perishable
from stevenson ranch
i don't know what is that okay uh
i don't know we just got something
there's some cheese you want cheese
parmesan cheese good things we give
every guest a small pack of parmesan
cheese
you can't leave without the cheese you
can't leave without this i'll put it
right here what is this wendy why did
you just bring this in
what is it you have to open the silver
you have to open the silver she says
you open it give it to the guest to open
okay do you want to open it okay okay
so you're going to pittsburgh and you're
going to be recording that's ice
um yeah and i'm going to be meeting
my
new team over there you have a new team
yeah
what are they called what is that
what is it
oh it's a cheese of you
it's cheese sculpture of me
thank you
why didn't it come with parmesan
oh my god who made cheese of me it's a
cheddar cheese of you where did that
come from wendy um it came well jessica
helped me get that made it came from
that company that makes the cheese
but it comes from the company that makes
cheese
that's great wisps you can go you so you
can personalize and send somebody would
you ever
have you uh
i've eaten these before these are good i
didn't know that you wouldn't actually
make courtney
it looks cool but i'm not a big fan of
cheese
are you lactose intolerant no
do you know what that is who doesn't
like cheese yes
courtney hadwin doesn't like cheese it's
not i don't like it i'm just not a big
fan of it
have you did you have as a younger child
did you have a run-in with cheese that
traumatized you no you've never seen a
cheese concert do you think of ch which
do you like better max martin or cheese
maximum okay have you ever got a good
question my daughter has the best
question courtney have you ever smelled
cheese yeah some of it smells pretty bad
huh yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
you